if you were on chinese social media at
the start of the year
you might have come across this video it
appears to show a tesla model 3 in
flames at a shanghai parking garage
the reports were widely watched and
shared on popular micro blogging site
weibo
and messaging app wechat in a statement
to chinese media
tesla said that nobody was injured and
the fire was likely caused by something
hitting
the bottom of the car and damaging the
battery before it caught fire
tesla didn't respond to a request for
comment on the video in question
other videos appearing to show quality
issues in vehicles sold by the ev maker
have surfaced on chinese social media
and after a number of customer
complaints tesla was summoned by chinese
regulators over safety concerns
casting a shadow over tesla's success
story in a country where the model 3
sedan
quickly became the best-selling electric
vehicle tesla
has been enjoying an honeymoon in china
was viewed
with adoring eyes people think tesla is
associated with the high-tech but now
with this
accumulation of complaints is going to
be a quite
major issue quality issues aren't new
for tesla
manufacturing problems have prompted
recalls and investigations in the u.s
in the past tesla has said it swiftly
addressed complaints from customers
but in the world's largest electric
vehicle market these quality issues
could threaten tesla's meteoric rise
tesla has pulled off some major feats in
the last couple years
globally its car deliveries and market
valuation have grown quickly
tesla first entered the chinese auto
market in 2013
when it opened a showroom in beijing and
started taking online pre-orders for its
model s
we're incredibly excited to break ground
on the shanghai
to your factory in 2019 tesla became the
first foreign car maker in the country
to run its own plant without partnering
with the chinese company
something local officials typically
require from foreign companies that want
to operate in the country
we want to very much say thank you and
appreciation for
the shanghai government and the support
yung xi wang is the director of a group
at uc davis
studying china's transportation energy
sector when tesla entered china
u.s china they were really in the middle
of a trade war
so there was a huge incentive to
showcase
that china is opening to the world it's
not discriminating
against foreign investment it took tesla
less than a year to get its shanghai
plant up and running
that's half the time it took to launch
its battery producing gigafactory near
reno nevada
after getting funding from chinese banks
and quick approval from officials
tesla was delivering its first
chinese-made cars to local drivers by
early
2020
and in early 2021 tesla started
delivering its model y
cars car sales in china brought in more
than 6.6 billion dollars in revenue for
tesla in 2020
and helped the car maker reach a record
500 000 global vehicle deliveries that
year
but then in early 2021 chinese
regulators reported an
unusual uptick of customer complaints
about tesla quality issues
in this online video for example a tesla
driver appears to complain about the car
accelerating without the driver's foot
on the pedal
with cruise control and autopilot
functions appearing to be turned off
tesla didn't respond to a request for
comment on this video
authorities say they held talks with
tesla on the consumer reported abnormal
acceleration
and battery fires warning the car maker
that it needs to abide by chinese laws
and strengthen internal management to
ensure the quality and safety of its
products
it couldn't be determined whether the
cars and the videos circulating in china
were made in shanghai
the company said it would investigate
the claims and abide by the law
it didn't respond to our request for
comment
industry observers questioned whether
the speed at which tesla scaled up
production in china
could have affected the quality of its
cars tesla
was meeting a huge demand in china there
was also some
rush that might contribute to the
quality and may
now be able to provide quality products
in time to meet their demand tesla
didn't respond to our questions on
whether production speed may have
affected quality in china
but elon musk has acknowledged in a
recent interview that the company has
faced production challenges
during that like production ramp that's
it's super hard to
you know be like in vertical climb mode
and get everything right
industry analysts said tesla's response
to regulatory scrutiny in china
differs sharply from the tone it is
usually employed with regulators in the
u.s
in 2018 musk sparred with u.s regulators
as they investigated his tweets about
taking tesla private when his company
was in a cash crunch
tesla never ended up going private and
in 2020
musk initially defied a california
county government order to suspend
production due to coronavirus
and at one point he tweeted the
coronavirus panic is dumb
tesla's issues in china right now aren't
necessarily unique
other ev makers including its rival neo
have also reported battery fires
but transportation analysts say tesla
needs to protect its reputation in a
market that already represents 20
of its revenue and is expected to grow
i think that they has to be more careful
than chinese local
companies and they're bigger and they're
perceived to be
a better company tesla's been allowed to
operate with relative freedom
thanks to a loosening of china's rules
for foreign automakers in 2018.
for instance many foreign car makers
like gm and mercedes were required to
partner with local companies
but the silicon valley company faces
increased competition from local
startups including lee auto and
x-pang as it hopes to continue to gain
ground in china
pressure from regulators comes at a
critical time for tesla